que les cherry avait karine le marchand
qui est indiqué dans 7 à vous sur france
5 elle est revenue sur la crise qui
touche les agriculteurs nombre des
agriculteurs
merci alors là on aime et qu'il faut
défendre et on espère qu'ils vont voilà
qui reviendront sur le bateau de
balances ton post mais freine spéciale à
la rentrée avec l'inde agriculteurs et
j'embrasse olivier mon ami agriculteur
qui n'est pas eu je vais laisser un
message à la fois olivier et il m'a pas
rappelée rien et qu'ils veulent donc
c'est qu'il allait jouer ensuite
derrière voilà donc leur brasse 6 me
regarde il décède m'appeler elle se
prend tellement au sérieux que jean
michel aphatie et nelly anne elisabeth
lemoine lui a demandé si elle voulait
s'engager en politique
karine le marchand eh bien regardez eu
sa réponse à karine par beaucoup de
remaniements alors après tout quelqu'un
qui s'investiraient dans l'agriculture
je pense vraiment je pense que mon sens
de la diplomatie n'a échappé à personne
et que si on me donne une responsabilité
your hands y aura mais ça va ou pas
parce que vous auriez agir j'adore
prendre le pouls de ce qui se passe et
j'aime donner la parole aux gens moi
mais la prendre pour dire ce qu'il
faudrait faire ou pas je pense pas que
je serai à ma place
mais par exemple quand vous entendez le
mit alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez
de ça jean-michel même pas karine parce
que l'on pose une question nous répond
mais je comprends même pas qu'on lui
demande s'il a envie de s'engager à
officia mais on entend tellement de
choses en fait c'est n'importe quoi
c'est on les accumule temps ils n'ont
pas besoin que d'une épouse ils ont
besoin de leur travail soit valorisée
qu'il ya ont négocié au niveau de
bruxelles et serra le prix du lait etc
c'est un boulot politis un boulot
économique ça boulot faut faire des
grandes études pour faire ça croyez moi
on l'aurait demandé aussi en revanche
elle aurait pu balayer d'un revers de
main beaucoup plus évident que ce
qu'elle n'est pas parce qu'elle a
terminée en déambulant pour le moment
oui ce serait entendu peut-être que là
pour l'instant écoutez c'est pas
d'actualité mais éventuellement je peux
me chauffer non elle a fait un message
beaucoup plus politique que j'ai noté l
à dire ne peut pas demander aux
agriculteurs de reprendre la charrue
alors que les patrons de l'industrie
agroalimentaire partent en vacances en
jet privé là je trouve qu'elle a raison
ça veut dire à luc mallet klein ça fait
pas des femmes peut garer le
marchandises l'agriculture c'est des
conneries mais on a eu trois conneries
je trouve que c'est pathétique mais
après elle participe et tous les médias
aussi participent à la peopolisation de
la vie politique ou absolument on veut
que bigard fasse de la politique afida
turner fasse de la politique
donc en fait finalement elle est
complètement aujourd'hui tendance par
rapport à ce qui se passe après elle
peut être totalement en empathie et
bienveillante avec les agriculteurs mais
qu'elle ne vit pas des quotas et des ah
bon voila voila je pense que vous pouvez
faire un peu parler d'elle au schisme
moi je pense sincèrement que c'était
pour le buzz et j'aime ça j'espère
vraiment que c'était pour le buzz parce
que pour moi c'est la dame qui a le
moins d'empathie ohrid
nokia va pas nous faire croire qu'elle
va s'intéresser aux agriculteurs quand
elle en tournage et kg de ses feuilles
parterre excellent et maquilleuse qui
les ramasse je sais pas si son côté très
humain va c'est gratuit
[Musique]
je préfère le dire pour les gens ah bah
voilà alors on va voir le sondage que
karine le marchand
j'ai un taux minoré psg est 4e à 4 1%
bon ben je crois que la mecque s'est dit
calme
on